actor Jeremy Pope I put 10 on him - is
being called Broadway's MVP why because
he is the first black man in Tony
history to earn two separate acting
nominations in the same season think
about that for a second the nominations
are [ __ ] performances in the play
choirboy and the musical ain't too proud
the life and times of the temptations
it's really good we met him at the
Copacabana the other day Copa Cabana
I like the Coco Cabana Cabana that's how
it's pronounced in New York City's Times
Square the other day we also then
stopped by the Imperial theater where he
now performs eight times a week as Eddie
Kendricks one of the temptations
founders
[Music]
that must never get old it was an
emotional moment when 26 year old Jeremy
Pope discovered that he was up for not
one but two Tony nominations when both
of them came the tears for you know
begin to swirl and I feel like both
productions got shown so much love why
did the tears come at that almond trees
came I think because of the sacrifice I
just felt kind of like a release of like
you did good you know and we'll continue
to keep working to what it's bigger and
better growing up in Orlando Florida
Pope says it was High School where he
caught the theater bug I had to choose
between running track or doing the
School Musical and I thought I just
auditioned for it and I ended up getting
like a lead part in cast what role were
you in Kat was skimble shanks and cats
and my dad made my costume your dad made
the costume it was orange fluorescent
tight it was just one one leotard and he
spray-painted it and gave it you know
some pizzazz thank you Dad dad how old
were you when you said I'm coming too I
was 17 when I told I had to sit down
talk at the dinner table I was like I
think I want to go to New York weren't
they expecting you to go to college they
were expecting me to go to college what
was that talk like Jeremy was very quiet
I was very nervous because I didn't you
know I you tried I remember I was in my
room and like okay what's the plan
they're gonna ask they're gonna say this
how're you gonna pay for it where you
gonna live well you know that I was
ready for all those questions and while
I had some of the answers most of the
answers were a question mark but I just
knew in my gut there was a fire there
was something that was telling me I
needed to go out there and get what was
mine clearly you were confident I was
confident and that I knew I would work
my butt off to make something happen at
the time there weren't a lot of Broadway
shows that
I saw myself represented in it was like
I could be Simba and Lion King but I
knew I'd get here and just work work
work working to figure it out Paul and
Silas Pope was first cast as Ferris in
choirboy I need to be put down
put out a role that he calls deeply
personal and life-changing I worked hard
to get where I am now in this school but
before his time his Ferris came to an
end
each day the Pope was already preparing
to take on the role of the late Eddie
Kendricks
[Music]
co-founder of the temptations how were
you able to pull that off it was a very
difficult time because I was doing
double duty meaning I was in rehearsals
from the morning 10:00 to about 6:00
during the day for temptations and then
at night I had to run over to the
theater to do choir boy I didn't want
there ever to be the excuse of Oh
Jeremy's doing to show so he's not able
to fully commit I didn't want that I
wanted it to seem like I was present in
both places it's a level of discipline
Pope carries with him even beyond the
stage trying to dis preserve the gift to
then be able to do eight times a week so
is that why you're talking quietly yeah
because I got serving your boys yeah by
the end of the day we need to be up to
Eddie Kendricks boss settles
[Music]
I feel like I look out to the house and
you know on one end you see the older
couple kind of singing along and
reminiscing and then to my right I see a
young black boy who's looking up and
finally seeing himself represented in a
commercial big Broadway hit and the
temptations still endure today you can
still go and see the temptations it's
funny because I get to uncle oh we call
him but remember of the temptations
after rehearsal he invited us to his
hotel room we sat there for five hours
and he told stories and just told us
about what it is and what it ain't
he's here to pass on the torch and to
you know tell us how to be consistent
and how to show up every night it feels
like a responsibility that I leave
Jeremy behind and I show up for Eddie to
some people out there they're getting to
see Eddie one more time you know and
that's just such a beautiful thing and
[Music]
it's also so as you point a very
physical role just we're dancing we're
moving were singing but my boys I have
to give it up to my cast members in the
show because it's the hardest show for
all of us it feels like a relay race you
know and we have to show up for each
other
[Music]
because I can't do my show without them
so we huddle up at the top of the show
and we're like you good you're good look
at each other and I like what you need
like I'm feeling a little and I'm I got
you I got to know did you do it every
night every show we hold each other and
we just look each other in the eyes
because we know that we can't do it
without each other what he's up for - as
you know 12 nominations for the
temptations and four for choirboy but he
gives a special shout-out to his mom and
dad his mom on opening night of choirboy
I love this story they got a call that
someone had passed out in the audience
that night opening night it was his
mother there she is Toshi Chapman she
had passed out in the audience guys she
was so nervous
she forgot to breathe she forgot to
reason woman I want to say a Broadway
actors job is incredibly hard yes it's a
very idea that he was rehearsing for one
show and showing up for another I mean
that's incredible and giving it his all
to both anthing because he didn't want
anybody say well you know he can't do it
he can't cut it so cheering you on your
really impressive you can watch the 73rd
annual Tony Awards this Sunday June 9th
at 8:00 7:00 central right here on CBS